Welcome back to our Emmy's extravaganza,
the Emmy celebrate television stars.
But today we wanted to celebrate
the stars of our show
that we call Drew-gooders.
So we took our "Six feet
from $600" game
to Hollywood
with two very deserving contestants
and a surprise twist.
Take a look.
(upbeat music playing)
(crowds cheering)
All right! Wooooo! Hey everyone!
We're here at the TCL Chinese Theater
on historic Hollywood Boulevard.
Otherwise known as the walk of fame.
We're going to do a special Emmy's edition
of our show and we're going to play
everyone's favorite social distance
game show,
"Six feet from $600."
We have two contestants playing today.
I would like you to meet Alicia.
And Jerry.
Now, Jerry, you're going to be up first.
Okay.
And Alicia, we're going to see you
in one minute.
Jerry is a pre-school teacher.
Now I understand
that during the pandemic,
you actually drove a school bus around
for a certain reason.
Will you tell me about that?
So my school closed down
and I didn't know what my next step
was going to be.
And I stumbled across a bus
on Facebook marketplace.
And then I converted it
into a mobile classroom.
And now I teach children in my community
in their driveways and our parks.
And I, I teach out of this really groovy bus.
(crowds clapping)
So Jerry, really quickly before we get started,
you have a little thing on your podium?
Yes.
Do you mind actually sticking it
on the back wall right next to the $600?
It's "6 Feet From $6000!"
Thank you, Jerry.
You're welcome!
That's absolutely perfect.
No, Jerry,
this is all about you
and we want you to win.
And today,
every question is going to be
Emmy related.
We're going to put 60 seconds on the clock.
In the Handmaid's Tale,
what color are the dresses
of the handmaids are required to wear?
Red, red or black?
Blue, black
Red or black?
Red.
Thank you.
What is Sterling K. Brown's character's name
in This Is Us.
Is it Randall Pearson or Jack Pearson?
Jack Pearson?
Randall Pearson?
Yes.
Okay. "Tell Cersei. I want to know it was me."
is a famous line from which show?
The Crown or Game of Thrones.
G.O. T.
Thank you!
Yay!
Oh, co-star Billy Porter
appeared on the Drew Barrymore show
singing to what?
A sandwich or a flower.
A flower.
_ Yeah!
Oh my God.
I love this show so much.
In PEN15, the lead actors,
they play 13 year olds,
but how old are they in real life?
21 or 31 ?
31. 31.
31. Good. You got it.
You got it.
Time's up!
Okay.
I feel like that's my bad.
Like I took too long.
Not your fault.
Thank you for playing!
Okay.
This show should be called six feet
from the scorching sun.
(crowds laughing)
It's a little hot, but it's okay.
Icarus.
Now, Alicia.
First of all, I want to ask
what do you do for a living?
So. I have the pleasure of helping people
to live out their dreams and their passions
by helping them start nonprofits.
So everything from working,
(crowds clapping)
working with the homeless
to youth mentoring programs,
you name it. We do it.
In fact, right now we've got a backpack supply
and food drive going on in Watts, California
for over 300 families that otherwise
would not have been able to have school supplies.
So.
Well, I'm going to donate my own $6,000
to that program.
Oh my God.
Thank you. Thank you.
Absolutely.
Your category is all about
the walk of fame.
Okay.
Kind of where we are right now.
Yes.
Let's see if you can win $6,000.
Okay.
All right, here we go.
Ready? And okay.
Which 11-time Emmy winners name
was misspelled on their star in 2010?
Julia Louis Dreyfus or Jerry Seinfeld?
Julia Louis Dreyfus.
Yeah! True or false?
Emmy nominee Anthony Anderson star
is located across the street
from his old high-school.
True.
No, false.
Yes, no. You were right.
Oh True!
Which talk show host is located
right in front of us,
literally his studio is right across the street,
Fallon or Kimmel?
Kimmel!
Yes!
Harry Belafonte became the first black performer
to win an Emmy
and also got to walk a fame star that same year,
the year was 1960 or 1950?
1960.
That's right!
This Emmy winning family
is one of the a few fictional characters
with the walk of fame and stars.
Is it The Simpsons or the Griffins from family guy?
The Simpsons
Yes! True or false.
The iconic boxer and Emmy winner
Muhammad Ali's star
is the only one mounted on a wall
rather than the ground.
True.
Yes!
(crowd cheering)
That's $12,000!
There you go.
Six feet apart.
That's right.
There you go!
Thank you!
That is for you!
And if I only had another one,
I would show it to the backpack program.
Maybe I can give you this one
for the backpack program.
Actually, I'm going to have to
give it to Jerry.
Thank you!
Next time, I'll go faster
and I'll get you there.
But nonetheless, you're going home with $6,000.
Thank you.
Guess what? That's six that's 12,
that's $18,000 right here.
On the Drew Barrymore show
with our favorite game show,
"Six Feet From $600 or $6,000"
(crowds cheering)
Well, congrats Jerry and Alicia.
We love you and we'll be right back.